[Applaudissements]
une petite chant en j'ime un petit
papier parce que je la connais pas toute
nouvell sur ton dernier disque elle
s'appelle vous les femmes vous les
femmes tu veux chanter oui avec ton
petit orchestre d'accord et qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire à ma façon tu veux
chanter on va bien voir alors on va
t'accompagner tu permets que je
t'accompagne oui bon d'accord alors à
mon 1
2 vous les femmes vous les femmes vous
pensez avec c'est comme ça que je chante
moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas bien mais non il manque un
petit peu de piment là tu sais pas de
chanson méditerranéenne et tout çaypte
là Égypte Italie l'Espagne fait tout ce
que tu veux les ENF t les pays quo
regarde regarde un petit peu comment je
chante vous les
femmes compris vous les j'essaye vous
les femmes voil
[Applaudissements]
on vous les femmes vous les femmes PZ
avec le cœur vous les femmes vous les
femmes vous énissez nos s vous les
femmes vous les femmes vous donnez tout
sans compter vous les femmes vous les
femmes simplement soyez remercié
encoreens vous les femmes vous les
femmes vous prensez avec le cœur vous
les femmes vous les femmes vous enéissez
nos œurs vous les femmes vous les femmes
vous donnez toutous en coné vous les
femmes vous les femmes simplement soyez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci je n'ai rien à dire encore un
petit peu un petit peu encore on peut un
peu encore hein oh tu es gentil un petit
peu j'ai rien à dire il faut quoi on va
pas arrêter l' t il faut que je lu rende
l'appareil moi alors laisse-moi te
t'imiter maintenant à mon tour avec le
Sound de claud bowling maintenant
[Musique]
pour les choses de cette maison te
regrettent autant que moi
elles ne veulent pas croire que tu m'
quitté oh qu'est-ce qui arrive encore
que tu m'es quitté vibrato oh j'avais
oublié bon excuse-moi ça va venir et un
vibrato 1 alors les choses de cette
maison te regrettes autant que moi
elles ne veulent pas croire que tu m'
quité plus chante ensemble chanter pas
ensemble une chanson on ch chanson voilà
voà voà famille on peut continuer Albert
un petit peu encore allez il est gentil
ce soir alt
[Musique]
profitons Dona Dona Dona
Dona tu
regretteras le
temps Dona Dona Dona
Dona où tu étais un
[Musique]
enfant à quel son jolis de mon
pays son jolis mon
[Musique]
pays
pay
[Musique]